منذ ايام ومدينه اوديسا حاضره في واجهه
مشهد الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا تحديدا
منذ انتهاء العمل باتفاق نقل الحبوب عبر
البحر الاسود
مواقع حيويه وتاريخيه في المدينه استهدفت
بقصف روسي بالصواريخ والمسيرات وفق الجيش
الاوكراني اهمها موانئ التصدير ومنشات
تخزين الحبوب وكاتدرائيه التجل التاريخيه
تعطيل موانئ اوديسا ومنشاتها الزراعيه
ينهي او يقلل لحد كبير امكانيه استئناف
عمليات نقل الحبوب بحرا بمعزل عن روسيا
والاتفاق مع الاشاره الى روايه الجانب
الروسي القائله باستهداف قواته مواقع في
اوديسا جرى فيها تحضير هجمات بالزوارق
والطائرات المسيره استهدفت وقتها مواقع
حيويه في شبه جزيره القرم وكذلك جسرها
الاستراتيجي الذي يربطها بالاراضي الروسيه
قبل هذا المشهد المزدحم بالتفاصيل الحرب
كان لمدينه اوديسا اهميه كبيره فالمدينه
المطله على البحر الاسود توصف لانها
العاصمه الاقتصاديه والسياحيه يمتد ساحلها
عشرات الكيلومترات مما يسمح بوجود عدد من
الموانئ اهمها اوديسا ويجني
وهي ثالث كبريات مدن اوكرانيا بعد
ويسكنها اكثر من مليون شخص تحوي مطارا
دوريا ومنشات صناعيه وحقولا زراعيه وفيها
مصانع غاز النيون الذي يستخدم في صناعه
اشباه الموصلات اضافه لصناعات بتروليه
وكيميائيه تاسست اوديسا عام
1794 زمن الامبراطوره الروسيه كاترين
الثانيه فاصبحت في القرن التاسع عشر ثالثا
اهم مدن الامبراطوريه بعد موسكو وسام
بيترسبورغ